[Music]
it is a prison warden's worst nightmare
inmates who take over the prison the 8
news now i-team is uncovering disturbing
details about what the state doesn't
want you to know the i-team's vanessa
murphy is shedding light on what appears
to be a cover-up
[Music]
inmates at medium security prison
southern desert correctional center
caused a riot on december 8. later that
day the state department of corrections
issued this press release calling it a
disturbance every officer who saw that
was like this is the biggest slap in the
face i've ever seen in my life paul
lundquist is the president of a union
which represents correctional officers
this was
beyond a bad situation for five months
the eight news now i-team has been
digging to uncover what really happened
just now we received this statement the
doc and the attorney general's office
are investigating officer conduct and
offender behavior during a disturbance
that day here's what we learned inmates
unlocked their own cells from the inside
refused orders covered surveillance
cameras flooded the area with water and
took control of an entire prison unit
they used a metal bunk bed frame to
block an entrance when officers busted
in and lined up in a formation the
inmates mimicked them with their own
formation some of them armed with
prison-made weapons like shanks
threatening to kill staff the ringleader
a known member of the white supremacist
aryan warrior gang every single person
that i talked to
expressed the same thing i didn't know
if i was going home to my family that
night
i didn't know if if we were all going to
make it out alive the i-team has learned
tasers were used along with pepper balls
flash banks and grenades with spray to
make it difficult for the inmates to see
officers report having trouble breathing
because of the smoke from fires the
inmates had set and pepper spray
lundquit says they didn't have the
resources they needed they should be
getting commendations not investigations
the i-team has learned there was a
scramble for officers to respond they
were called over from high desert state
prison an employee was even called in
during a sick day the clark county fire
department metro police and other
departments were on standby and while
publicly the doc claims 20 to 25 inmates
were responsible for what happened the
i-team has learned internally at least
40 are considered to be direct
participants and the department had
planned to move more than 100 to other
institutions while the doc claims minor
injuries were treated on site the i-team
has learned an officer was hit in the
head with a rock and at least one inmate
needed to go to the hospital and finally
the doc also claims the disturbance
happened around 1 p.m but the i-team has
uncovered trouble began five to six
hours earlier they really don't want
anyone to know what's going on out there
they don't want anyone to know how badly
they're failing the accountability is
zero for administration we've repeatedly
requested interviews with prison
leadership the department continues to
decline our requests we also reached out
to the governor and a spokeswoman says
he doesn't have anything to add other
than what the doc told us and by the way
there is video of what happened we
requested it along with documents about
the riot the doc has refused to provide
it vanessa murphy live local now